Stuart Eizenstat served as US ambassador
to the European Union from 1993 to 1996
during his tenure he took part in
negotiations to determine restitution
from banks and private companies
throughout Europe for their roles in the
Holocaust
imperfect justice is his insider's
account of German slave labor Swiss gold
and the ultimate settlements this talk
runs about an hour thank you very very
much
Carla is a particular pleasure to be
here because I feel like I was present
at the creation many years ago when you
came to see Fran and me in our house and
discussed the concept of a bookstore and
everybody rolled their eyes except you
you've made this possible with your
vision and your great work and you and
David have been role models of public
service and friendship for us for for
many years it's a particular pleasure to
see so many friends and also colleagues
people who worked on these negotiations
people who helped with the research of
the book I appreciate all of your
efforts and wouldn't be here but for
those it's also a special pleasure to
have my mother who is here she's moved
up recently from Atlanta and my wife
Fran who was a partner in this
enterprise from start to finish I'd like
to also particularly recognize Austrian
ambassador Moser stem master we
appreciate you coming and there are many
people from the US government including
Randy Bell the ambassador who has taken
over the responsibilities that I had and
who's done such a fantastic job with it
my book is really an empowered whilst
Ori of how belated and imperfect justice
was finally provided to long-forgotten
Holocaust survivors and other victims of
the greatest robbery in world history
more than fifty years after the end of
World War two it's a story about how
some of the world's most powerful
corporations were finally made
accountable for their wartime actions
and it exposes
how fresh and contemporary the wounds of
World War two still remain even today
it's a tale of political intrigue a
bitter conflict of threats of sanctions
of international diplomacy at the
highest levels together with a colorful
cast of characters worthy of a
Shakespearean play it started from me on
a typically wet and dreary Brussels
January day with an unexpected telephone
call from Richard Holbrooke then
Assistant Secretary of State for
European affairs asking if I would
undertake what he assured me was a
limited mission of a few months on top
of my duties as US ambassador to the
European Union what I serve as a special
State Department envoy to encourage the
new democracies of Eastern Europe to
return communal property synagogues
churches schools community centers even
cemeteries confiscated from the
religious communities by the Nazis and
then later nationalized by the communist
governments of the old East Bloc frankly
I didn't immediately accept my staff at
the US mission in Brussels unanimously
argued against it they said it would
divert my energies from my already
consuming job with the European Union
and that it would be unlikely to be
successful my fellow ambassadors
throughout the Eastern Europe were not
enthusiastic about my intruding on their
turf pursuing an unpopular issue so with
all of this why did I disregard the
advice and start down a path which would
take not a few months but full six years
would end only in the last hours of the
Clinton administration and affect the
lives of millions of victims of world
war ii jewish and by the way non-jewish
indeed the majority of funds that we've
obtained are for non-jews in Eastern
Europe to answer this a little bit of
background I grew up in Atlanta Georgia
in a home in which Judaism was a
pervasive influence grandparents born
in Eastern Europe a father and two
uncles who served in World War two and
yet the Holocaust was at least to my
knowledge never once discussed I never
met a Holocaust survivor I never took a
course in high school nor college about
the Holocaust and indeed even if I had
been interested in it I couldn't because
there was no college courses almost
anywhere in the United States in the
1960s about the Holocaust when I was
growing up the dominant issue was
segregation and my earliest memory of
confronting injustice had nothing to do
with the Holocaust it was a test I
failed as a teenager when I couldn't
break with convention and offer an
elderly black lady ladened with shopping
bags my seat in the white only section
of Atlanta bus my lack of recognition of
the Holocaust and the survivors in
effect mirrored the worlds as well
the fate of Hitler's civilian victims
Jews Slavs poles Jehovah's Witnesses
gypsies was sealed in 1938 at the Evian
conference when the great democracies of
the world refused to lift their
immigration quotas and open their doors
when there was still time during the war
there were no ringing declarations from
any Allied leader of the consequences
that would flow from the genocide they
all too well knew was occurring indeed
decades later I met a wonderful man who
only recently passed away Yann Karski a
brave Polish diplomat who twice risked
his life going into the warsaw ghetto to
bear witness and then told his story
directly to President Roosevelt in the
Oval Office and as course he told me he
said that FDR listened and passively to
his story and then sent him to his
trusted confidant Supreme Court justice
Felix Frankfurter after hearing Karski
out the great jurist paused for a moment
and said sir
I'm not saying you're lying I simply
choose not to believe you after the war
the fate of survivors was little better
the British kept 52,000 survivors trying
to enter Palestine in squalid camps in
Cyprus for years those who had the
temerity to try to return home and
reclaim their homes and properties found
them occupied and they themselves were
driven off or in the worst case even
murdered hundreds of thousands of
stateless refugees drifted without hope
into displaced persons camps only to
find a lad and American military forces
completely unprepared to deal with this
new reality conditions were so
deplorable in the DP camps that
President Truman appointed a personal
envoy Earl Harrison who in a scathing
report to the president said mr.
president we appear to be treating Jews
as the Nazis treated them except we
don't exterminate them they're in
concentration camps in large numbers
under our military guard instead of SS
troops spurred by newsreels in movie
theaters across America of gaunt faces
stick thin bodies in striped uniforms
bulldozers piling heaps of dead in
trenches there was a transitory horror
and an initial burst of activity by the
Allies to return all moveable property
to the countries but not to the
individual victims from whom it was
stolen only a fraction ever reached its
intended owners and when the Iron
Curtain descended on Eastern Europe and
all private II private property was
nationalized almost any hope of recovery
seemed to be ended post-war negotiations
with the neutral countries for the
benefit of refugees and the rebuilding
of Europe particularly with the Swiss in
an attempt to return looted gold and to
liquidate German assets in their
position possession dragged on for years
and only a small percentage of what was
owed was ever paid any remaining efforts
to recover what was stolen ended with
the Cold War the American focus was on
incorporating into a Western alliance
against the
past enemies vanquished nations and
former neutrals the knee not suffocation
programs in Austria and Germany were
terminated and only Germany after six
years of silence about the Holocaust
paid for the plight of victims and then
only those who lived in the West Austria
also had a series of partial restitution
programs for property the victims
themselves were too weakened to intent
on rebuilding their own shattered lives
and new countries to seek recovery and
so justice for victims seemed to fade
into the mists of history
it appeared forever and yet something as
monstrous as the Holocaust and this
enormous theft of property artwork bank
accounts and the light could not be
forgotten slowly almost inexorably it
made its way back onto the world agenda
and into my own consciousness many of us
know Michael Berenbaum and as a
Holocaust scholar he has said that
paradoxically the more distant we are
from the Holocaust the larger it looms I
began to come to terms of the Holocaust
as did many others in 1961 with the
Adolf Eichmann trial in Israel the
chilling image of an unrepentant Nazi
methodically unemotionally testifying in
a glass-enclosed bulletproof witness box
was my first opportunity to confront the
Holocaust through the vision of one of
its chief perpetrators but I had an even
more important and personal experience
in 1968 when I was working on the Hubert
Humphrey campaign one of my co-workers
was Arthur Morris who had just published
a path-breaking book called while six
million died which exposed the willful
indifference of the Roosevelt
administration in the clear face of
evidence of genocide our conversations
during the campaign about his findings
had a profound influence on me so that
by the time I entered the Carter White
House in the 1970s I was prepared in
1978 to recomm
to President Carter a Presidential
Commission to determine a suitable
memorial to Holocaust victims which led
ultimately to the u.s. Holocaust
Memorial Museum a year later in 1978
determined not to repeat the same
mistakes that Arthur Morse had pointed
out my predecessors in the Roosevelt
White House had had I persuaded
President Carter to reinterpret the visa
laws so that 50,000 Iranian Jews fleeing
the first radical Islamic Revolution
could enter the United States and so by
the time I received that telephone call
in 1985 from dick Holbrooke the
Holocaust had reentered the world stage
with novels and histories with movies
and hundreds of college of courses
college courses and with a new Holocaust
Memorial Museum inaugurated in 1993 15
years after my recommendation by
President Clinton and yet still why now
why 50 years later why did justice for
survivors suddenly reappear on the
world's agenda in the mid-1990s there
was a unique combination of historical
events which came together at precisely
the same time together with a few
individuals who took advantage of that
confluence of events one was the
implosion of communism just as the Cold
War aborted any efforts to help refugees
after the war the end of the Cold War
permitted those behind the former Iron
Curtain for the first time to be able to
travel it opened up archives it freed up
energies to look at the unexplored and
unforgotten part of World War two and it
roughly the same time while I was
serving in Brussels there was a
proliferation of World War two related
50th anniversary commemorations
d-day the Battle of the Bulge in the end
of the war in Europe all LED journalists
and historians to look back at the
unexplored past in World War two
one of those journalists was Pia
Gumble who wrote a front-page story in
The Wall Street Journal in the summer of
1995 about World War two Swiss bank
accounts established by Jews to keep
their assets out of Hitler's clutches
but never returned to their former
owners
he gave a human face to that story
Greta beer an elegant articulate and
sympathetic now elderly lady in Boston
who had spent literally decades going
through Switzerland trying to locate her
father's bank account only to have one
obstacle after another put in her path I
read that story in my office in Brussels
and I called Holbrooke up and I said I'd
like if you could extend my mission from
Central Europe property restitution to
Swiss bank accounts I wasn't the only
one who read that story Edgar Bronfman
the debonair billionaire head of
Seagram's and president of the World
Jewish Congress and his top executive
Israel singer of brilliant mercurial
flamboyant Orthodox rabbi absorbed the
political import perhaps better than I
did of Gumble story and understood that
this issue could elevate the World
Jewish Congress to a new status in the
Jewish world
it was Bronfman one of President
Clinton's chief financial and political
backers who activated the President to
get me involved and as one of Senator Al
D'Amato's most important New York
constituents convinced the senator which
took I might say little convincing to
hold hearings on the Swiss bank practice
up for re-election just at that time
D'Amato pivoted out went his dead-end
Whitewater hearings in came the Swiss
bank hearings he hoped his ticket to
re-election as Senator in New York in
our litigious country where there's
controversy there are lawsuits and where
there are lawsuits there are colorful
class-action lawyers who sued the Swiss
banks we now had a genuine three-ring
circus with me as the unwanted
ringmaster
the Swiss bank in Brolio brought the
whole Holocaust restitution issue front
and center and what happened then was
really quite unusual because events
unfolded like peeling back the layers of
an onion one discovery led to another
one set of lawsuits to another one
negotiation to the to another first the
Swiss then the Germans then Austrian
companies last French banks issues long
suppressed like the failure to return
Nazi looted art in the hands of public
museums the world over suddenly became
subject to new international rules that
I helped negotiate my book gives a
personal account of some of the most
interesting and difficult international
negotiations in recent years I can
assure you it's not an idyllic exercise
in moral expiation or the willing
provision by major foreign corporations
of Justice to long-suffering victims the
negotiations were torturous the tactics
used by the opponents of the foreign
companies brutal class-action lawyers
and Jewish groups persuaded state and
local officials to threaten sanctions to
get regulators to try to block mergers
by Swiss and then German banks took out
full-page ads and newspapers excoriating
German companies and while trying to
mediate these class-action negotiations
myself and our very dedicated US
government team again many of whom are
here had to balance the interests of
Hitler's victims on the one hand many US
citizens against our own genuine foreign
policy interests in good relationships
with the Swiss Germans Austrians French
and others when I finally caught my
breath in the waning hours of the
Clinton administration and closed out
the last negotiations with the hourglass
in our administration almost ended I
look back at a wildly implausible set of
accomplishments thousands of communal
properties returned to the reawakened
Jewish and other religious communities
in Eastern Europe the publication of
over 20,000
Swiss bank accounts with possible or
probable Holocaust connections quite a
contrast to what I was told in nineteen
nineteen ninety-six when I made my first
trip to Switzerland and talked to the
Swiss bank Association and was told that
they had done their own investigation
and there were 775 not 20000 and indeed
there's an even longer list of over
50,000 with some possible connection 8
billion dollars in settlements of
class-action suits against private Swiss
German Austrian and French companies
payments that will soon be made to one
and a quarter million surviving slave
and forced workers overwhelmingly
non-jews in Eastern Europe who had not
gotten any benefit from previous German
reparations bank profits from the Aryan
ization of private property finally
disgorged
and property returned insurance policies
paid and the adoption of the Washington
principles on art revolutionising the
art world and leading to the return even
as we speak now of hundreds of looted
artworks to their owners each
negotiation had its own character its
own set of actors which told much about
the nature of the nations with which we
were dealing and their ability to come
to terms with their past the most
difficult negotiations were with the
Swiss the proud neutrals the criticism
by the lawyers by American politicians
and the World Jewish Congress was the
most bitter the threats the most
menacing and the country the least able
to deal with the harsh spotlight of
history given their traditional
isolation from the currents of world
politics while Swiss citizens were
literally manning the tunnels and
passages and the Alps to keep the
Germans out their government invented
the J stem to keep Jewish refugees out
their companies were employing slave
laborers in Germany and their central
bank ignoring repeated Allied warnings
purchased massive quantities of Nazi
gold some five billion dollars in
today's value which they knew as
as 1941 to be looted and they did so
until the last weeks of the war they
were repeatedly warned and by the Allies
not to do so there were formal
declarations in 1943 and indeed an
agreement in February 1945 only months
before the end of the war in Europe and
two weeks later when the deputy chair of
the Reich Bank came they reversed
themselves and continued to trade in
gold to the final days of the war that
goal was converted into hard currency
which the Germans used to purchase raw
materials from other neutrals needed to
sustain their war effort and to compound
the problem after the war when there was
absolutely no danger or threat the Swiss
strung out negotiations for years and
returned only a tiny fraction of eluded
gold and German property they held
ironically their private banks were left
to pay the full 1.25 billion dollar
settlement the Swiss National Bank and
the Swiss government made no
contribution at all the aftershocks of
our negotiations still resonate in
Switzerland today Germany on the other
hand was once again willing to face its
past on top of the 60 billion dollars
that they have paid and continue to pay
to Holocaust survivors since the early
1950s they dug down deep once more into
their public pockets to match the amount
that their private companies were
putting up for settling the slave and
forced labor negotiations coming up with
a total of 10 billion door marks or five
billion dollars there were real heroes
in the German talks Chancellor schröder
the current chancellor who contributed
five billion Dortch marks at a time he
was sharply cutting back popular social
programs and Mal counterpart count at a
lamb's Dorf the great elder statesman of
German politics Austria unlike Germany
was only beginning to come to terms with
its World War two record when our
negotiations started still clinging to
the myth
that they were the first victims of
Hitler's ons loose rather than his
willing accomplices and yet Chancellor
Wolfgang chisel and a coalition
government with the Freedom Party of who
org Haider its xenophobic leader reached
a billion dollar settlement and in the
process the Chancellor and Austrian
industry wrote a new and happier chapter
in Austrian history and I'm glad to
acknowledge that with the Austrian
ambassador here last was France proud
France which finally came to terms with
its Vichy past which every French
president from the gall to Mitterrand
had denied vie she was an extra French
entity for which France was not
responsible France was indeed
exceptional during the war the only
Western European nation which was
conquered and actively collaborated in
anti-jewish activities with the
courageous leadership of President
Jacques Chirac together with our
negotiations France finally faced its
past and acted according to its best
principles I've asked myself many times
and I know my colleagues have given the
hard work they did was this all worth it
was it worth 6 years of effort tens of
thousands of hours of dozens of senior
US government officials including
President Clinton and his top White
House staff and are there any longer
term implications to this well I think
certainly for the victims it was worth
it not by the way that any have gotten
rich none will when you divide 8 billion
dollars over so many people you come to
a few thousand dollars apiece although
for those in Eastern Europe this amounts
to almost 1 years per capita income and
will help some elderly survivors have
greater dignity in their remaining years
but more important so many victims have
said to me that their greatest
satisfaction is simply knowing that
they're suffering during the war was
finally not forgotten and for the
reemerging Jewish and other religious
communities in Eastern Europe
the communal property they are now
receiving back is providing them with
the physical infrastructure to rebuild
and dig deep and permanent new roots
there are critics who have ballooned
what they call the monetization of the
Holocaust that somehow this degraded the
memory of the Holocaust itself but in
all modern societies monetary damages
are an accepted way of compensating for
wrongs why should those who suffered one
of history's most grievous wrongs not
have the same benefit in effect we've
come face-to-face with the same world
dilemma in the aftermath of September
11th how do we place a value on a human
life taken by an act of terror at the
end of the day we come back perhaps
grudgingly to using money as a rough
surrogate for correcting mass injustice
but our work I think goes far beyond
monetary recovery first I believe that
the most lasting legacy of our work is
simply encouraging the emergence of
truth truth about the dimensions of the
massive theft of property throughout the
methods and countries used by the Nazis
to sustain their war effort truth about
the previously unredressed in justices
to civilian victims historical facts can
and often are suppressed for a very long
time but I think we've demonstrated yet
again that eventually these facts have a
way of bubbling to the surface
indeed memory not money should be the
last word of the Holocaust and that's
why we were able to persuade the
presidents of Germany and Austria to
offer very moving apologies for their
country's mistreatment of forced
laborers it's why we had three
international conferences in Washington
London and in Vilnius and then a fourth
in Stockholm in which over 40 countries
the former vanquished former victors
former neutrals for the first time got
together to explore the past it's why we
encourage the opening of wartime arc
and led the way by declassifying over a
million pages of US government documents
it's why we got 21 countries to
establish historical Commission's from
Argentina to Lithuania from France to
Switzerland and including the United
States to review their role during World
War two and their handling of looted
assets and by the way the Swiss and
French Commission's were the most
searching and the most honest because
education is the perpetuation of the
truth we helped create a 16 nation
Holocaust education task force which is
operating today to spread Holocaust
education through the length and breadth
of Europe and in the United States and
school systems all over the continent to
teach not simply the most difficult and
suffering that the victims went through
but what happens when intolerance and
the rule of law breaks down when good
nations and good people stand on the
sidelines for too long in the face of
injustice a second long term implication
is the advancement of human rights by
for the first time in the annals of
warfare holding private corporations
responsible for their participation and
the violation of human rights by ripping
off insurance policies and bank accounts
by employing coerced labor by refusing
to return property and profits it was in
many ways 55 years later the civil side
of Nuremberg and I hope that this will
have long-term implications and that it
will act as a prophylactic for
multinational companies investing in
countries with difficult regimes and
that it will raise their standard of
behavior indeed our Holocaust cases have
spawned a whole generation of new class
action suits using similar principles
and arguments Korean comfort women and
American POWs suing Japanese companies
African Americans suing US companies for
their involvement in slavery victims of
South African apartheid suing us come
is for their alleged role and seeking as
did we reparations and historical and
audit committees even Armenians have
sued companies for the Armenian Genocide
of World War one the outcome of these in
a court of law are frankly unclear our
cases were won in the court of public
opinion not in the court of law but even
though the outcomes may be uncertain I
think the message is clear human rights
violations by private companies must be
taken seriously third our negotiations
open the window to a new type of foreign
policy for the 21st century one not left
to traditional government to government
negotiations a new set of actors
nongovernmental organizations like the
World Jewish Congress state and local
officials using their financial leverage
sometimes with great headaches to myself
and our team to affect foreign policy
decisions traditionally left to the
federal government and yes even
class-action lawyers all insisting on a
seat at the foreign policy table for the
first time the US government was
involved in resolving purely private
lawsuits what we engaged in an effect
was a massive alternative dispute
resolution process outside the court
system this was without precedent we
developed novel concepts some of which
are now being used in the 9/11 cases and
may be used in the future and other mass
acts of terrorism concepts like rough
justice to pay mass numbers of people
identical amounts because we recognize
the impossibly time-consuming effort to
individualize recoveries loose standards
of proof that would never have stood up
in a court of law
so that slave and forced laborers and
claimants for property laws have a
chance of recovering in an
administrative process a ceiling on
attorneys fees those who say that this
was somehow a Holocaust industry we
capped attorneys fees at 1% of
recoveries normally in a class-action
suit those can be as high as 33 percent
or even more we
establish the novel concept of having
the US government file a statement of
interest to help dismiss court cases and
send victims to a claims process far
swifter than any recovery in court and
again with our friend from Austria hear
that statement of interest may come into
play and the last remaining cases and I
hope they'll be successful in dismissing
the Austrian cases so we can get the
last several hundred million dollars
paid in Austria as I look back then and
in conclusion I drove myself and my team
unmercifully because we had a very
narrow window of opportunity when a
whole series of events came together
which would not come together again I
did so frankly to partially remove a
stain over our own country's history
our country sacrificed so greatly to win
the war but had done so little during
and after the war for its civilian
victims I was often also driven by an
abiding principle of Judaism imparted to
me by my parents and it's why it means
so much to have my mother here called
tikkun olam meaning to repair the world
in this case too imperfectly repair
lives torn asunder during World War two
recognizing how much we accomplished and
painfully mindful of how many were never
helped who died over the past 50 years
and could never be benefited and indeed
how imperfect was the justice we were
able to obtain even for those who did
survive in the truest sense there can be
no final accounting for the devastation
wrought by the Nazis to human lives and
property which is why I've called the
title of the book imperfect justice I
think in the end of the wonderful
indefatigable lady who went throughout
Switzerland looking for her father's
bank account and in many ways started
the whole process Greta bier who never
to this day has located her still
missing Swiss bank account she's called
me frequently to say
and these words mr. secretary don't
forget me please don't forget me mr.
secretary well I think history will not
forget her nor others who were
courageous enough to step up and be
counted
and who had had justice so long denied
so I closed this book and this chapter
in my life with an ancient proverb from
Pirkei Avot ethics of the fathers and
that is it is not your obligation to
finish the task but neither are you free
to exempt yourself from it thank you
very much
since since this is a heavy topic let me
start the question period off with a
with a humorous story that was told to
me when I was in the Carter White House
by Russell long who was then the senator
from Louisiana very colorful and
chairman of the Senate Finance Committee
and whose father was the even more
colorful Huey Long the governor of the
great state of Louisiana during the late
1920s and Russel recounted that when he
was growing up as a young boy in Baton
Rouge in the governor's mansion that
Papa came home one night stone-cold
drunk
staggered up the stairs and with great
difficulty reached into his pocket to
get the key to the governor's mansion
with a very shaky hand finally got the
key in the keyhole to Al and turned the
key the door opened and Russell hanging
on to mama's apron string saw papa just
collapsed in the foyer
only to have mama with her hands crossed
looking sternly down at the floor to see
how this state of affairs could have
occurred to the governor of the great
state of Louisiana and Russell said Papa
said the following mama I've completed
my prepared remarks now now take
questions from the floor
so in a very different state I'll now
take I truly honor what you've
accomplished I want to ask a question at
the time that you were working on this
in Africa there was a genocide occurring
yes during the Clinton administration
and I include myself is you know
responsible for not taking more action
in light of what you've learned and your
involvement in the Clinton
administration how does you know
government you know
become involved to try to prevent death
things like this video question is that
during our administration while I was
doing this work there was a another
genocide occurring in Africa this was of
course the Rwanda and how do we sort of
square this and what lessons can we
learn there first of all the President
Clinton himself has said he feels that
the greatest mistake he made from a
policy perspective in the White House
the greatest moral stain if I can put it
that way was the failure to intervene
and to do more to stop a genocide that
led to a meet and a half to two million
people being being slaughtered and I
think it indicates how easy it is to
accept genocides when they don't seem to
directly affect your national security
interest in the case of World War two
it's very difficult to parse out
Roosevelt's thinking but certainly one
of the factors was that he did not want
to make this a war for the Jews and that
if it was perceived as a war for the
Jews at a time when there was
significant anti-semitism in the United
States he was concerned that it might
affect the war effort now even given
that there is so much more that could
have been done privately I think what
happened in Rwanda is inexcusable it
demonstrates to me the need for the UN
to have some kind of permanent force
that will intervene in circumstances
like that but if the United States
doesn't take the leadership and we
didn't then these kinds of events will
occur again so I think it indicates how
far we
still have to go and that when we talk
about this task force that we set up the
16 country task force to learn the
lessons of the Holocaust it ought not to
be limited just to the Holocaust it
ought to be limited to other genocides
and try to activate the conscience of
the world to deal with the role the
Future Rwanda so that this doesn't
happen again yes hi you spoke earlier
about how you hope that your work will
serve as president to push forward human
rights law and events on that front my
question for you is also are you
concerned that what you've done and the
president said also be used as a
political tool in cases that are perhaps
not so clear-cut the question is will
lists in some respects act is a
political tool for cases which aren't so
clear-cut I think the answer is it has
the potential to do it to do so but in
effect what happened here as I mentioned
was that these court cases and eight
billion dollars in settlements did not
occur because there were victories in
court quite the contrary
except for one judge every Court that
ruled on these cases dismissed them
every single court it was won in the
court of public opinion and so I would
say to you an answer the question that
those cases whether it's the apartheid
cases the slavery cases which carry
public opinion which have enough weight
behind them to carry public opinion will
be successful and those that don't will
fall of their own weight is there
further work being done there the
question is is the is the work finished
if the work were all finished then Randy
Bell who's in the back here would have
nothing to do and he has a great deal to
do I think it's fair to say that a lot
of what and John Becker as well a lot of
what the major negotiations are all done
it's very difficult to conceive that
there will be any other major
negotiations and payments are being made
in all of those negotiations I don't
want to go into great
but in every one of the cases the Swiss
case the Austrian case the German case
the French case real money is going out
to real people I mean in the German case
1 million 135 thousand people have
already received awards almost 2 billion
marks and euros rather and more will go
out so the major work is still to be
done it has been done but there is
cleanup work and important cleanup work
the Austrian cases have to be dismissed
there is still art that has to be
returned and recovered there is communal
property and Randy was in Eastern Europe
recently to encourage the further return
of communal property there are 3,000
pieces and Poland alone where if I may
say so when I do in my book if the
problem in the return has not been with
the Polish government it's been
disagreements between the local Jewish
community and the international Jewish
community about who will control those
so there is still a lot of important
work to be done but the major
negotiations are finished and real money
is going to real people but thankfully
before it's too late
in those major cases men if it had not
started with your Eastern European
situations if there hadn't been the
implosion of the Soviet empire could the
United States have started it with
regard to the Swiss or would that have
been politically impossible question is
whether it would have been politically
impossible if there hadn't been an
implosion in communism and would it
start would it have started with this
whistle I really don't think that had we
not had this unusual unique confluence
of events the the end of the Cold War
and particularly the 50th anniversaries
of World War two that this would have
gotten started at all we had one other
factor which is that the survivors are
reaching the end of their natural life
cycle they were now more comfortable
about telling their own story they
wanted some justice in their own
lifetimes but I think that it was that
confluence plus again some some
reporters and people who wanted to take
political advantage of it and thankfully
they did it's difficult to see without
that combination Matt that that this
this might have occurred out of a vacuum
I mean let's
or that for 50 years the Swiss banks
that successfully kept that money and
let's let's understand also in the
United States if you and I have a bank
account in first Union Bank and we have
no activity in that bank account for say
10 years the money the the legal term is
as cheats to the state in which the bank
is located so it would go to Maryland or
the district or or wherever in
Switzerland unlike the United States and
in much of Europe if that if those
accounts are dormant for ten years the
money doesn't go to the state it goes to
the banks and so there was a distinct
advantage in their doing so now it's
very interesting that in many ways the
report we did in 1997 been in Freeman is
here who helped me with that and milk
horseman and others we began to peel
back what the Swiss had done but it took
their own Historical Commission
professor Berger to go into more detail
and just a little anecdote and that is
that judge Corman is one of the heroes
in the Swiss case he helped he helped
lead to the final settlement help me
conclude the case and just a few months
ago after the book was almost finished
he called me up from his a courthouse in
Brooklyn and he said you've got to look
at the Burgi a report on this particular
page and I said why and he said because
it shows something that you didn't know
and that I didn't know after all the
work we did and that was he the Berea
report uncovered a 1954 memorandum from
the major Swiss banks which said that it
should be our policy to do everything
possible to keep depositors from getting
these accounts back I mean it's just
absolutely explicit so they were
successful for 50 years they would have
been successful for another 50 years yes
and as a survivor but who speaks no
English are there plans to publish your
book in other languages yes it'll be
published in german by Bertelsmann it'll
be published in in French by Sol and
we're still trying to get an Israeli
publisher so it'll be at least in three
and three languages and by the way for
people around the world there are
websites in multiple languages informing
them of how to apply for claims the
Jewish claims conference in New York and
Jerusalem is handling the slave laborers
for the forced laborers in Eastern
Europe who believe it or not there are
still a million and a quarter left and
that leads me just to tell you one story
because I think it's quite phenomenal
one of the things we really found out is
how the war was financed and operated a
large part of it was looted gold some of
which was victim gold gold teeth jewelry
that was smelted into disguised gold
bars and thence went to sent to
Switzerland converted into the hard
currency I mentioned but the other way
in which Germany was able to feel such a
huge standing army seventeen million
people in a country at that time even
with the on Felucia had about 70 million
was that there were some 10 million
forced in slave labourers when they
occupied a country they took the
working-age men they put them in the
farms and factories in Germany and that
freed up Germans to to go to the front
and there are still at least a million
and maybe a mean and a quarter Eastern
European non-jewish forced laborers who
are getting paid and they're getting
paid through so-called German
reconciliation foundations which have
been set up German checked German
Russian German Ukrainian German Belarus
and so forth so and then one last
organization called the International
Organization on migration is handling
those forced and slave laborers in
Western Europe so we're trying to do it
in people's languages and again there
are websites there newspaper
advertisements and so forth which are
informing people Jason
I'm sorry well I was curious with why
Richard Holbrooke started it was his own
Jewish background okay the question is
why did Richard Holbrooke start the
phone call it had nothing to do with his
Jewish background although his Jewish
background is interesting
his grandfather was Jewish and Fran will
remember that when when we went to his
embassy and bond when we were in
Brussels he had a dinner in our honor he
had a very prominent picture of his
grandfather in a World War one military
outfit with the pointed hat Nall as he
said to tell the Germans this is what
they lost no it had nothing to do with
that yeah I can assure you it had
nothing to do with it a dick Holbrooke
is a very talented guy who has very good
political antennae and he realized when
Edgar Bronfman and Israel singer came to
see him about property restitution which
mat started at all it was not the Swiss
bank issues that started that this was
an important guy who had to be listened
to and they asked him who should do it I
happened to be in Brussels and that's
how it started so it was really
political pressure and the political
pressure again I have to tell you is a
central feature of this you have to
understand that political pressure at
every level the matos political pressure
against the Swiss the brahmans political
pressure with respect to the Clinton
administration was seminal in getting
this started now the fact is that during
World War two Jews did not apply that
kind of political pressure on Roosevelt
it was a very different era there was a
concern about any Semitism everything
was done very quietly FDR was never
under public Jewish pressure to do
anything had he been there would have
been perhaps a very different outcome
yes with the increase in anti-semitism
in Europe I'm wondering if you what the
public opinion in Europe has been of of
these findings yes the question is with
the curtain the question is occurring
any Semitism in europe and i'd try to
deal with that in the conclusion of the
book it's a very difficult topic let me
let me sort of answer it in two separate
ways first of all except in Switzerland
there was no increase in a nice
as a result of our negotiations the
Austrians absolutely none even hiders
parties supported the agreement in
France none in Germany none in
Switzerland there was and Christoph
Blocher the far-right populist leader of
the freedom party vaulted his party to
the second leading party in the
parliament the Swiss government never
blessed our statement not only didn't
negotiate in every other case we would
never have gotten the kind of huge
settlements we got if the German
government hadn't matched the
contributions of their private industry
if the French government hadn't helped
match their private enterprise
contributions if the Austrian government
hadn't done the same the Swiss
government didn't they stayed on the
sidelines they never even blessed the
settlement now the second issue has to
deal with the broader issue of
anti-semitism in Europe today and this
is a topic on for another speech but
just in a paragraph the overt actions
which have occurred against synagogues
and so forth are largely a result of the
North African immigration in places like
France but it's too easy to dismiss the
issue as only a North African issue and
I think one has to say two things in
addition one is just like in the United
States where politics matter in pressure
matters it matters in Europe as well
there are now 7 million Muslims in
France against 500,000 Jews and that
makes a difference politically a second
and there is no question but there still
is in some quarters I don't by any means
say in most there is still in some
quarters in Europe of veneer of
anti-semitism that has sort of covered
itself in an anti Israeli attitude now
look I have problems with the Israeli
policy myself in some areas but what's
happened in Europe has gone so far as
treating Israel as if it were a pariah
state you know a modern-day apartheid
South Africa boycotting Israeli
universities and the like that one has
to say that there is at least some
remaining veneer
in some quarters in some quarters of
broader anti-semitism yeah yeah can you
talk about say a few words about the
immediate post-war period during the
Truman administration what efforts were
made at that first opportunity at
property restitution in Europe and why
that was unsuccessful and what
precedents are created for your work yes
Truman the question is the early
post-war period why and what more wasn't
done first of all a great deal was done
the US troops in particular were
remarkably selfless with only one major
example exception rather in in the so
called Hungarian gold train where some
American generals literally took
Hungarian Jewish valuables and and used
it for their own personal use American
troops were remarkably selfless in the
way they dealt with what they found and
what did they found I mean just imagine
this if any anybody remembers the
Indiana Jones movies and the Raiders of
the Lost Ark I mean the last days of the
war American troops are plowing toward
Berlin and they come on this salt man
call the Merkers man and they come into
this man and they found unbelievable
vast amounts of gold gold bullion we've
got pictures of it in the book
gold jewelry boxfuls and boxfuls and
boxfuls of it nobody they may have been
a few people who put this or that in
their pocket but by and large that and
other movable assets like art the policy
of the United States which was the
international policy at the time was
when you have something that's been
looted you return it to the country from
which it's looted and it's their
responsibility to return it to the
individual victims I mean there was no
way for the United States
to land up individual pieces of jewelry
or gold bullion or even artwork with
individual owners so they gave it back
to France and to others what happened
then is not a happy picture because
there was not a great effort to then
and the victims many of course had
perished those that were returned to the
countries behind the Iron Curtain that
property was nationalized so whatever
effort was made and it was considerable
for a year or so to return the property
got completely lost in a black hole when
it was returned to the countries and
they did very little to try to locate
the the victims bookie I'm particularly
grateful to collar for surrendering the
seat so I could sit here because I
wouldn't have missed a word of what you
said today it was an absolutely
brilliant presentation and I look
forward to reading the book but as I was
doing that in quelling about you because
I've known you for 35 years now maybe
more
I keep recording oh by the way bookie
and I first met in the 1968 Humphrey
campaign and he reminded me at that time
he was twice as old as I am and now he's
only 1/3 old or so he's obviously stays
still and I've aged much faster sir I've
had many occasions where I was proud of
you and all but on vacation about 15
years ago still finished a very very
successful tour of duty with the Jewish
Community Council use the mic I'll make
a speech book banner was the longtime
head of the American Jewish Committee in
Washington stew who is so busy all of
his life took on the assignment that
many of us thought was not sufficient
for him but he became a very impressive
head of the Jewish Community Council a
Jewish Community Center in Impa that in
Rockville but one day when he retired
from that job I was asked to present an
award to him so I was very pleased to do
it and I remember that I hadn't planned
it but as I was extolling this man it
suddenly occurred to me the
say that this man has set a record as
the youngest elder statesman in the
history of the Jewish community I can't
say that anymore that's for sure yes I'd
like to thank you from a very personal
point of view because my parents are
Holocaust survivors from Vienna and I
just wanted people to realize that in
being part of a class action suit er
being involved in this we are now in the
possession of a stack of papers this
high documenting from not all through
1938 which is when they had to fill
these out and then we're able to leave
in the last few moments luckily all the
assets all the requirements the Jews had
to observe all the taxes that the Jews
had to pay and and watching the assets
just Windell as each of these decrees
come out so we have a whole family
history now you know and whether there's
money at the end of it to us is less
important than what this has meant to us
so I really thank you I appreciate that
she was talking about her own family's
history let me just say with respect to
property claims that the way we treated
this and this you know gets into the
whole issue of slavery the slavery
questions as well
with respect to slave enforced laborers
we had to make a very difficult decision
and that is that we could only pay those
who survived so of the ten million again
they're about a million and a quarter
maybe a million and a half we'll know
when the claims period is over we simply
could not pay heirs I mean it would have
been an astronomical and unaffordable
number however with respect to property
claims and including insurance and of
course art and real property businesses
and apartments and the like heirs can
claim and we have a so called in rem
process if you can actually identify
your property you can get that back if
it's occupied then you can get at least
some fair market value but in most cases
and again this is just why I called an
imperfect justice we had to put a cap on
the amount that was available for
property claims so that when we get all
of the claims a grenaded will then on a
pro-rata basis to vad that it's just the
best we could do but at least people
will know that they have some connection
art work is different art work is
personal you can get that back not the
fair market value and under our
Washington principles very loose
standards of proof and basically the
concept is that if you hold a piece of
looted art you're supposed to return it
to the original owner that's non-binding
but forty countries send up to that and
we hope that they'll they'll follow it
and most most have now give some very
interesting examples in the art chapter
of people who found their art through
very unusual circumstances and and we're
finally reconnected after 50 years with
their with their art yes I suppose
pleasure to work with you doing this
project now that this chapter in your
life has ended and you're out of the
government administration what do you
see as next on your drawing board what's
your next prime spending some time with
my wife thank you again for coming and
thank you for your interest
Stuart Eizenstat is author of imperfect
justice looted assets slave labor and
the unfinished business of world war ii
it's published by public affairs on the
web at public affairs books calm